wir wollen direkt rein schauen in dieser
dramatischen bilder die uns aus der
zweitgrößten stadt in der ukraine
erreichen und julian du bist bei uns
erklärt uns was ist was genau sehen wir
hier ja so zeigt etwa zwei stunden war
seit einer stunde finden schlimmste
angriffe der russischen armee afr aktiv
statt und zwar mit mehrfach
raketenwerfern das heißt da werden
tatsächlich von vor der stadt raketen
abgefeuert ungerichtete raketen keine
präzisionswaffen sondern waffen des des
kalten krieges waren diese auch schon im
zweiten weltkrieg gab die katjuscha
waren das damals und die schlagen hier
wild im zivilen gebiet ein und wir
wissen mittlerweile dass es dort
dutzende tote gegeben hat bei diesem
russischen angriffe und es gibt offenbar
noch weitere russische angriffe stunden
wir haben den ganzen tag darüber
gesprochen wie mutig sich die ukraine
wehren und kämpfen aber dann sieht man
eben diese aufnahmen und sieht wie ja
chancenlos da vielleicht auch die
ukraine sind wenns sowas kommt dass hier
aufnahmen aus einem wohnblock wo man
eben sieht wo da die raketen ein und
durchgeschlagen sind julian ja was wir
hier sehen also man kann es kaum glauben
das sind große wohntürme wie man sie
vielleicht auch aus deutschen vierteln
kennt berlin marzahn beispielsweise so
in der art dass dort aus ich war selbst
noch einmal noch aktiv aber das ist so
etwa vergleichbar
und dort schlagen diese großen raketen
ein interessanter weise was wir sehen
und das zeugt noch mal von diesen
unfassbaren kriegsverbrechen die putin
dort beginnen lässt was wir sehen ist
nicht etwa eine nicht explodierte rakete
sondern eine von der die sogenannte
bomblets diese ganzen kleinen bomben
abgefallen sind das heißt in diesem
wohnzimmer ist quasi wenn man so möchte
die die trägerrakete gelandet und die
etwa 50 kleinen bomben die da dranhängen
sind links und rechts des hauses
eingeschlagen noch mal reinschauen in
dieses video weil das einmal auf zeit
das ist wirklich bis vor kurzem hier
nämlich ein schreibtisch wo die fotos
drauf stehen also vor kurzem saß
wahrscheinlich hier eine familie hat ja
gegessen gearbeitet und
eben die die fotos sich gemeinsam
angeschaut und jetzt also schlägt hier
diese russische rakete ein durchs dach
oder durch die wohnung die darüber liegt
also an gucken oder das ist unfassbar ja
noch einmal von anfang an dass man es
einmal sieht also hier riesige krater wo
die rakete am ende stecken geblieben ist
die tapete oben ins kommen durch die er
ist ja mehrere stockwerke durchschlagen
ich sie jetzt hier nicht dass darüber
direkt der himmel ist wahrscheinlich ist
ein weiteres stockwerk noch drüber das
ist diese unfassbare wucht mit der diese
diese raketen kommen damit das loch im
also ich muss leider sagen ich acht
jahre lang den krieg in syrien mit
verfolgt so sieht es dort aus also genau
das daran erinnert mich dass diese
großen löcher dann die raketen die
dadurch fallen und wir werden
wahrscheinlich gleich sehen draußen ist
das bild noch viel schlimmer denn dauert
draußen sind diese ganzen kleinen bomben
diese ganzen kleinen mitgeführten bomben
dieser raketen eingeschlagen vielleicht
bevor wir rausschauen das erklärt ja
auch noch mal diese sirenen die unsere
kollegen die die menschen in der ukraine
jetzt seit tagen hören das erklärt warum
ist diese serien gibt die menschen die
sollen sich eben in sicherheit in den
keller bringen denn wirkliche sicherheit
gibt es sowieso nicht mehr aber es kann
eben sein dass selbst in meinem massiven
wohnblock am ende die raketen
durchschlagen und mich in meinem eigenen
wohnzimmer meinem eigenen kinderzimmer
mich um meine familie töten und
vernichten muss man sagen und man muss
auch sagen was wir jetzt gerade und
kreativ sehen das finde ich immer
wichtig das ist wahrscheinlich das was
wir auch in kiew sehen werden archiv 1,4
millionen stadt also durchaus
vergleichbar mit hamburg zum beispiel
hat auch die russische armee am ersten
tag versucht reinzugehen das hat nicht
geklappt die wurden dort
zurückgeschlagen von den ukrainern und
jetzt kommt sozusagen der plan b von
putin also dort die stadt zu vernichten
und die menschen zum fliegen zu zwingen
und eben zivilisten zu töten wir schauen
jetzt einmal raushören hat schon
angesprochen aufnahmen die nur schwer zu
ertragen sind wir zeigen sie deswegen
nicht im ganzen aber sie zeigen doch wie
tödlich die waffen und munition von
wladimir putin ist denn hier rechts da
werden wir gleich sehen da liegen eben
dann menschen die getroffen sind die
sich in diesem moment zumindest nicht
mehr bewegen mehr wollen wir davon gar
nicht zeigen aber das zeigt eben
menschen sind nicht mehr sicher wenn
diese raketen am ende kommen und
einschlagen julia ja wie du gesagt hast
also es ist glaube ich in ordnung dass
wir das das wird das nicht zeigen aber
wir können zumindest sagen was wir dort
sehen ja es ist einfach die realität des
krieges wir haben also menschen dort
gesehen die den die gliedmaßen fehlen
die teilweise noch lebend sich in
hauseingänge geschleppt haben ohne beine
ohne arme wir haben vom ukrainischen ist
der ihm dass es dort dutzende tote
gegeben hat bei diesem angriff alleine
und nochmal die angriffe gehen dort
weiter das heißt russland hat setzt
tatsächlich darauf das ist nicht das
zentrum der stadt ist eine riesengroße
stadt trier ist ja vielleicht einmal
anschaut genau wir uns da eigentlich
bewegen und warum diese gerne sondern
warum diese stadt so wichtig ist genau
gucken uns mal hier aktiv so etwa an und
da oben auch die russische grenze kann
ich irgendeine farbe haben ich danke dir
rot für dich genau wir sehen dass das
die russische armee hier überall
vorgedrungen ist und sie ist am ersten
tag und auch vorgestern auch im kgb
attraktiv eingedrungen ich zeige dass
bloß mal so das ist alles schon von der
russischen armee besetzt und sie wurde
wieder vertrieben aus aktiv das heißt
die stadt hält weiterhin stand die stadt
wird von ukrainischen soldaten
verteidigt und dieser angriff den wir
heute gesehen haben oder diese angriffe
die zur stunde anhalten waren nicht im
zentrum von raki sondern waren eher in
den nördlichen bezirken hier und das ist
eine aktive von putin gesehen haben auch
2014/2015 dass man sich tatsächlich den
ja meint man schießt sich den weg frei
man ohne rücksicht auf verluste ohne
rücksicht auf zivilisten
dort der gesamte weg freigeschossen um
eben dann ins stadtzentrum zu gelangen
irgendwann mörderische blutige raketen
die das muss man einfach mal wirklich
betonen nicht gezielt auf militärische
ziele auf flughäfen auf kasernen
geschlossen werden sondern die
willkürlich in wohnblocks einschlagen
und dort am ende familien oder aber vor
allem eben zivilisten töten und treffen
die das auf jeden fall ein kauf nehme
ich will ich ganz lang willkürlich wilke
und ich fing auch bei anderen wichtigen
können die wohnung schon absichtlich
dorthin geschossen aber die die taktik
die putin hier verfolgt wie auch in
syrien ist die taktik wenn dort niemand
mehr leben kann dann können auch die
feindlichen soldaten dann nicht mehr
leben
grausame ja eine grausame taktik eine
grausame motivation julian vielen dank
wieder für deine analyse